the calls are endless every single day
of the week at whatever time day or
night
melissa fatala runs a non-governmental
organization
that has redirected its resources to
providing oxygen supply to coronavirus
patients
at home there is what doctors call an
uncontrolled pandemic in lebanon
i had a gentleman call me at 11 30 at
night on saturday crying on the phone
because of his father
and i had to you know explain to him i
physically do not have a machine right
now please wait until we get a machine
and he's like my father can't wait
there is a shortage of machines to
provide patients with oxygen
leading to more appeals on social media
for help
we have a lot of patients receiving care
at home and
less and less patients being admitted to
hospital
because the places are full
the red cross has been at the front line
of this battle
volunteers have transported more than 5
000 patients to hospitals in the past
few weeks
four times more than last year and there
are many more
on a waiting list 75 percent and
a big number of them are critical
patients so if they can't get
at least oxygen or another care that
they need
it can affect them some hospitals are
using shipping containers to treat
patients in the parking lot
while others have suspended
non-emergency treatment
health experts say lebanon registered
one of the world's
worst surges in infections in january
for the size of its population
which is close to seven million
including one and a half million
refugees more than one hundred thousand
cases were detected in the past months
that's one third of all cases identified
in the past year many countries have
dealt with bed shortages and the need to
prioritize
care but lebanon's health sector was
already weak
from years of neglect and a collapsing
economy
a high number of cases for sure led to
drainage of all the resources that we
have
luckily we did not reach the time where
we need to remove a ventilator from a
patient to give it to another patient
who is more needing
but if we continue like that i think
soon we will reach this phase
a three-week 24-hour curfew has brought
numbers down
but it's not enough and the daily worry
of not being able to find a place in
hospital
or get access to oxygen supplies hasn't
gone away
senator al-jazeera beirut